para este apicultor de la situación es
nefasta
miren todas estas colmenas todas vacías
totalmente abandonadas por las colonias
de abejas que tenían aquí pero uno de
los cerca de 2.000 apicultores
sicilianos nunca ha visto algo similar
este verano perdió más de la mitad de
sus abejas cuando una ola de calor sin
precedentes golpeó la región
de verano fue una tragedia por el calor
extremo las temperaturas se acercaron a
los 50 grados muchas de las abejas
murieron o dejaron las colmenas que se
convirtieron en infiernos viven pavón
forma como consecuencia de estas
temperaturas récord los incendios
devastaron la zona miles de hectáreas
fueron consumidas por el fuego
destruyendo la vegetación que es
esencial para las abejas estos insectos
a su vez son vitales para la
polinización de tres cuartos de los
cultivos
mira todos estos árboles se han ido para
siempre tenemos que replantear todo como
significa la destrucción de un bosque
como este resultará en la desaparición
de la fauna y de las pasturas que son
fundamentales para las abejas con y
bilic a dipascali perle a estos
incendios han destruido las floraciones
de finales de verano y principios de
otoño
con o sin flores no hay néctar para
alimentar a las abejas fortunato
apicultor durante 28 años no tiene otra
alternativa más que alimentar
artificialmente a las sobrevivientes por
primera vez
esta es una mezcla azucarada salada moss
para contrarrestar la falta de fuentes
naturales de alimentación de otra manera
corremos el riesgo de que la colonia de
abejas muera durante el invierno
pero esto no ha sido suficiente para
salvar la producción de miel que ha
caído en un 70% este año en la isla una
crisis sin precedentes que ha obligado
al gobierno local a declarar el estado
de emergencia para la industria apícola
en sicilia